[Music]
I'm sorry I thought touching without
permission is what you wanted
I'd let me pass unless you want to know
what it feels like when the liquid in
your eyeballs assists Eliza's
M&S next time you want to talk come
yourself don't send your alcohol to
attack me did you start the fight I'm
gonna sing au revoir it's what you my
third-favorite henchmen which we always
say never start a fight you can't finish
hmm and not my dears what you my
favorite you listen well apparently you
don't
and how Amina out out of was out of
options out to your mind after the
closet there's just so many outs for the
lady in blue are you asking you the same
you should know by now I don't ask that
anything I tell and I take I want to
show you something miss Byrd is very
rich
step handy yeah a toast to the future
mrs. Alan West and West Alan although
your life with Barry may be fast-paced I
hope you guys take the time to enjoy the
special moment thank you guys for coming
it really means a lot
Cheers well all right who wants my
champagne craziest thing I get to do
tonight is order two desserts I'll take
it that's right iris told me you were
pregnant it was like going yeah it's
good it's good I mean it wasn't exactly
part of my plan but I just could not be
happier I know exactly what you mean oh
yeah how is everything with Oliver and
William do I hear wedding bells ringing
in your future
oh no the last time we did anything that
resembled a wedding Oliver got habanero
so uh did you girls order a stripper why
don't you tell me what about always
singles no I girl you know some freaky
stuff I mean that wants you uh Caitlyn
do you know him you need to come with me
we're not going anywhere with you please
tell me that this is just part of his
act if it is it's taking too long
take it off
whoa Emmett
everybody we got a whole bunch of new
flash to break down we got some
Constantine too because he's coming to
legends of tomorrow so I'll explain
what's going on with that and we found
out that John Noble from fringe and like
a billion other things like Lord of the
Rings is coming to legends of tomorrow
as the big bad so John Noble is the big
bad for legends of tomorrow his name is
malice but let's start with this flash
stuff because Katee Sackhoff is making
her debut on this show so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything
they'll be giveaway stuff at the end of
the video so there are a couple Easter
eggs in this killer frost clip if you
didn't spot them there's dark size Omega
symbol as she's walking in the posters
peppered outside the door advertise a
karaoke night just a reference to the
karaoke episode from way back in season
1 been a long time since we've seen that
version of Caitlyn and then she walks
through the hallway there's a bunch of
graffiti I can't read all of the text
but there's a giant cat head the biggest
cat in the DC Universe is Dexter he's
one of the Red Lanterns now I don't
think the TV show is ever gonna do a Red
Lantern cat before they do Green Lantern
and I don't know if they're ever gonna
be able to do Green Lantern but when
they have scenes like this they can do
funny graffiti like they can just do
winks at things even if they're never
intending to do them on the TV show so
it's not like they're saying they're
going to be doing Green Lantern stuff
even though there's been Green Lantern
Easter eggs in the universe before like
Ferris air is a location inside Central
City so there's already a lot of Green
Lantern stuff happening but the whole
thing here is just to give you a sense
for what killer Frost's new personality
is like and this sort of merged version
of Kaitlin in killer Frost's so
previously we've seen like the
full-blown bad killer frost
and we've seen Kaitlin who's like the
complete opposite of that but it seems
like what's happening this season is
that it's sort of like a fused version
like remember last season when they
started to break through to her and her
eyes went from being really shiny to
being normal like that version of
Kaitlin
so she has access to all of her power
like she says to that dude before she
gets ready to stab him with an icicle I
thought unwanted touching was what you
wanted
but obviously the real action of the
scene is her talking to Amunet black and
probably the biggest surprise is that
Katee Sackhoff is
with a British accent so if you watch
Battlestar or you watch Longmire Earnie
of the other TV shows that she's on it
blows your mind just a little bit but if
you've never seen her before then you're
probably just like okay great new comic
book character but if you're not
familiar with their powers I'll talk
about it a little bit more during my
episode video tonight but she has
Meccano Kinesis so in the other trailer
they released a little while ago which
I'll link at the end of this she just
forms a big shield out of random metal
that's on her body that's what all the
metal studs on her dresser for like
obviously you know they want to make
cool-looking costumes but she can
actually use that to form a metal fist
so like imagine her forming a metal
gauntlet around her hand and then
punching you with that but the whole
thing here is that she's just running
this underground ring of rogues she sort
of filled the vacuum the captain cold
left when he took off like he used to be
top dog rogue then there was mirror
master he left so now we have Amunet
black that's sort of taken over
everybody but because Caitlyn is trying
to be Caitlyn and she doesn't want to be
killer frost anymore she tries to leave
very familiar story you try to leave the
super secret team up but they won't let
you leave and I know there are a lot of
questions about Captain cold too because
now it seems like she's gonna be this
version of killer frost and look like
this for most of the rest of the season
I don't know about the last couple of
episodes but they've already started
filming episode 10 and 11 and she still
kind of looks like this so she might be
this version of the character for the
rest of the season after this episode
but sort of separately a lot of you been
asking me about captain cold because
Wentworth Miller posted this very final
sounding Instagram message where he just
thanked everybody for the awesome time
he's had with the character so pretty
much every news outlet is like Wentworth
Miller leaving the role of Captain cold
in the air overs so people are like what
the hell is going on but just reading
this it sounds like he might be one of
the people that winds up dying during
the big four-way crossover and they do
like a citizen cold version of him it's
really cool but that's sort of his way
of going out in a big blaze of glory but
because we're on season 4 the flash now
and the producers have said that they
could go eight or nine seasons there's a
billion flash stories that they could
tell if they really wanted to they could
always bring him back in a future season
for a cameo or a small role
captain colt is probably not gone a
hundred percent it just sounds like he's
not going to be featured on the shows
for like the next year or so like in the
way that they've gone very reverse
flashlights he's not gone for good
it's just they did so much of him in
previous seasons that they want to give
the character a little bit of a break
before they bring him back but as we
learn more
I'll post new Captain Cold stuff because
he's such a huge character and there's a
really big comic book arc that Amunet
black is involved with that leads into a
big Captain Cold story so I'll talk
about that during my Easter Egg video
tonight but the big thing that
everybody's been talking about recently
is Constantine coming to legends of
tomorrow but they're bringing
Constantine back for two episodes so
episode 10 in episode 11 he's gonna
perform an exorcism in an asylum but
beyond that we don't really know what
the story is going to be but I think
it's sort of a test run to see if they
bring the character on as a series
regular next year but let me know in the
comments what do you think about the new
version of killer frost this season and
what will happen next is is I do have
some new Justice League stuff to post
before the flash tonight so if I can get
it done in time that I'll post it
there's a new round of that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on the
video congratulations to the winner from
the last video Jordan Vasquez please
private message me so I can get your
contact details you can click here for
that four-way crossover teaser and you
can click here for brand new Justice
League vs Darkseid thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight